tell me how fabulous life gets when
you're a big time Hollywood actress best
friends with George Clooney himself I'm
not best friends with you you got
married at his Villa George is a very
good friend of ours but he and John are
very tight John and George are good wow
how wonderful John and George how
amazing this must be it was wonderful
and would you decide to get married at
his Villa in Italy yeah now what goes on
with that who approaches this job
George's house we did we didn't have
aunts and uncles but we had like you
know we had the immediate family yeah so
George says why don't you have your
wedding at my castle he said we were
having sushi and he said congratulations
blah blah blah and he went you're gonna
get married at my house and we went no
no we thought he was just saying that
like when people just say that right and
they don't mean it and then he asked
again and we went no we're not gonna do
that and then he asked again and then we
said take me through this so now you
decide to get married to George
Clooney's house and you're kind of
insecure saying to yourself gee does he
really mean this yes how far should we
go with this yeah so now you have to
check in with Clooney so how many people
do you invite to your wedding we had 65
it was very small 65 people which is a
you're having 65 people to George
Clooney's house yeah yeah in a way
wouldn't it be simpler just to have it
somewhere where you don't have to answer
to George Clooney Italy was a very
special place for us it was where we
took our first holiday and everything
and so is that where you first made love
to your husband when you were dating no
we've been dating a while before we went
to Italy so you say to your family guess
where we're getting married or do you
play it cool again like it's no big deal
we're getting married at Clooney's I
think they knew that we were friends
because we'd been on holiday at his
house so who caters the event if I may
be so uh Geo works with George who kind
of runs George's holiday
Geo is an incredible guy who used to run
head of he used to be head of security
at the Venice Film Festival the guy
looks like he's killed people and he's
incredible and he planned our entire
wedding Gio did he was amazing security
guy he was like if for me I would get
these flowers if it were me I would have
this guy and you listen to him because
100 now do the people stay at George's
house or do they stay at hotels
surrounding George's house we had some
people who knew George who were kind of
you know people who he'd work with
stayed at his house right and then
everyone else stayed at two different
hotels so the upper tier
like in other words if I was a guest
coming to you might be allowed in his
house do you know uh I do know George
then you'd be allowed to stay at his
house absolutely you think I think he's
you know he wants people who he knows
people who know me tend to keep me out
of their house
I
Duty regularly